welcome to hari sadhus the Jannah where
we discussed the latest tech news and
delve into the newest tech products so
today we're taking a look at whether GPU
practice will ever go up like they did a
couple of months ago and what the future
of GPU crisis looks like but before we
get into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to stay updated with the latest tech
news related to gaming and pcs so as you
guys already know the Mayan craze along
with inflated Ram prices more demand and
stock shortages all combined together
led to the crazy inflation of GPU prices
for the last couple of months some cards
were even several hundred dollars over
their MSRP for example the MSRP of the
GTX 10 atti
is seven hundred dollars however you
could often find this card selling for
over 1,200 dollars on Amazon eBay and
lower level cards were really no better
most of them were overpriced by hundred
to two hundred dollars and what makes it
even worse is that this situation
persisted for several months in fact for
the rx 500 series the issue started over
a year ago and that issue still persists
today fortunately however GPU prices
have come down since then and many cards
are actually even hitting MSRP even
extreme examples have almost completely
subsided for example the GTX 1080i which
is $500 overpriced a couple months ago
it's not only $35 over MSRP which is
still not good but it is definitely a
significant improvement many cards are
getting to the lowest price they haven't
offered this whole entire year so as a
result I think that it is safe to
conclude the GPU price inflation is
finally drawing to a close and all GPUs
will reach MSRP or even B MSRP in the
next couple of weeks so finally that's
all over and we will never have to deal
with any of that again right could that
all happen all over again well to fully
answer that question I think that is
important to analyze what caused the
price inflation in the first place so I
think there were four key issues that
the price inflation or at least set to
cause a price inflation these issues are
the mining craze inflated ramp prices
extra demand and not enough supply so
let's start off with the easy ones what
is happening to demand well demand is
increasing every single day because more
and more people are changing from
console and going over to PC especially
because of the extra value that AMD has
been offering for the past year so it
makes transitioning on to PC much more
affordable for most people so as a
result the demand for PC parts and GPUs
this keeps increasing every single day
however as long as there is enough stock
that wouldn't be an issue so how is MD
and Nvidia handling the stock issue well
the first time that the stock issue
happened many gamers were very angry on
Nvidia and AMD for not doing anything
about it
and while miners may provide Nvidia and
AMD with great profits over a short
period of time
gamers are definitely the long-term
consumers of their products as a result
it is safe to conclude that AMD and
NVIDIA both want to keep the market
happy and last time mr. Jensen Wong who
is the CEO of Nvidia was actually very
disappointed that they could handle the
stock issues better so as a result I
think that is safe to conclude that even
if Nvidia and AMD don't have abundance
talk to be able to provide for the
demand they will definitely handle
another stock shortage in a much better
manner so next what about RAM prices
well unfortunately Ram prices are still
really bad however if you guys haven't
already noticed the GTX 280 has already
broken MSRP and the GTX 1060 is not far
behind at only 10 dollars over MSRP at
$260 instead of 250 so as you guys can
see despite Ram crisis being so inflated
GPU prices are actually still MSRP and
this actually happened a few months ago
too for example in November and December
of last year Ram crisi were just as bad
but at that point there wasn't as big of
a demand for GPUs and as a result GPUs
were still being offered for MSRP
despite the RAM pricing situation and
considering the Nvidia and AMD
are able to offer their gpus for MSRP
despite the RAM pricing situation it is
evident that Ram pricing doesn't affect
the GPU market too much ask to change
the MSRP so finally will there be
another mining boom well unfortunately
this is something that we cannot control
and if my boom does occur and the mining
boom can take advantage of GPUs that
definitely GPU prices will once again be
inflated but what we can do is we can
look back at what happened last time and
see what resolve the issue so there was
three things that deterred miners from
buying GPUs anymore the first thing was
the constantly decreasing prices of
cryptocurrencies across the board
the second reason was a constantly
increasing difficulty to mine
cryptocurrencies and finally the third
reason was the introduction of ASIC
miners for popular crypto currencies
like etherium we can't control the price
or the difficulty to mine crypto
currencies however however if this were
to happen again I'm sure that ASIC
miners will be introduced onto the scene
at a much earlier time in the
cryptocurrency mining boom because right
now as it's been proven selling to
minors can be very profitable and
generate a lot of revenue in a very
short period of time so since this has
been proven now more businesses are
willing to take advantage of this and
try to capitalize on it and as a result
we are more likely to see an ASIC miner
earlier on in the cryptocurrency mining
boom so well GPU prices go up as rapidly
as it did last time well first of all
demand is increasing every single day
however now AMD and NVIDIA are much
better prepared to handle such a
situation and ask for RAM while GPUs are
fastly approaching MSRP or already hit
MSRP despite the bad Ram pricing
situation and on top of this this is
pretty much the worst time period to buy
Ram so as a result if GPUs can be
offered at MSRP with the current given
Ram pricing situation then it is clear
that Iran does not have too big of an
effect on the pricing of GPUs finally
what if there is another mining boom
well first of all Nvidia and AMD will be
much more prepared to deal with this and
on top of this ASIC miners will probably
pop up Adam
much earlier time so as a result these
two factors combined will make another
GPU mining boom much less harmful for
the consumers you have to remember the
last time a lot of things negatively
worked together the release it Rison
brought in a lot more demand for PC
parts and especially GPUs concurrently
Ram prices had already been increasing
for a couple of months nvidia and AMD
were unprepared and finally this was the
first mining boom that we have seen so
as a result such a combination is quite
unlikely and even if it does happen
nvidia and AMD will be much more
prepared and ASIC miners will pop up
much quicker and as a result the prices
will not be as inflated as they were
last time so what's such a bad situation
occur one more time well in my opinion
no but what do you guys think do you
guys think that Nvidia and AMD are still
unprepared to handle such a situation
and how do you feel about GPU prices
finally hitting MSRP make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments and
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this together and make
sure to drop a like and hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to see more videos just like this but
until next time bye
[Music]